[MUSIC PLAYING]
SERHAT UNSAL: We're
going to take you
through a short journey
in the next 50 minutes.
So sit back and relax in these
beautifully comfortable chairs.
And this is going to start
with a background on Dawn Foods
and how this 100-year-old
manufacturing
company became a global
leader in the bakery industry.
And we're going to look at
some of the strategic insights
and the business case
that led into the thinking
of digital
transformation at Dawn.
Then Sam is going
to take us through,
together with our
partner [INAUDIBLE] here,
on the specifics
of this journey,
what the journey looks like,
and how the end product will
look like, what the
technical architecture is.
And towards the end, we're going
to provide you with a demo,
if everything goes
well as planned.
It's going to be basically a
showcase for the possible, what
we can do with this system.
And at the very end,
last 10 minutes,
we're going to take
your questions.
And our chief digital
officer, Bob Howland
is here with us today.
So we're going to
invite, kindly,
Bob to join us
with the questions.
So I don't know if you've
ever heard of Dawn Foods.
It's one of the best kept
secrets of the business world.
It's a family-owned,
privately-owned company
that's been in
business since 1920,
so almost 100 years,
headquartered out
of Jackson, Michigan.
It's a bakery
ingredients and bakery
products manufacturing company.
And what started as a small
donut shop in 1920 in Jackson
evolved into this $2
billion global company
with more than 4,000
people working for it,
operating in more
than 100 countries,
serving 40,000
customers every day.
And we have more
than 650 people who
are touching these
customers on a daily basis.
And Dawn operates in all
regions of the world,
but we are much bigger
in North America
where we have a unique
business model, which
we're going to talk about.
Because in North America,
we're not only a manufacturer,
but we are also a wholesale
distributor of bakery goods
and bakery supplies into
the baking industry, which
is vertically integrated to
our manufacturing business.
And what we do is we not only
manufacture our products,
but we distribute these
products to the end user
with our own logistics
systems together
with a bunch of other
products that are sourced
from third-party suppliers.
We have about 30 distribution
centers across North America.
And these distribution centers--
these distribution centers
serve about 20,000 customers
every day across North America.
What do we sell?
I mean, we really sell
anything that a bakery needs,
but we can group these things
into five categories, roughly.
We sell non-bakery
foods like your nuts,
raisins, cream cheese.
We sell processed
bakery ingredients
like a donut mix, a cake mix,
a brownie mix, jams, icings.
We sell raw ingredients like
sugar, flour, shortening, oil.
We sell semi-finished
and finished products,
like a decorated cake in a box.
If you shopped at Walmart,
bakery products there
are made by Dawn, most of them.
So we also sell non-food
products and services.
We sell baking equipment.
We sell pots, pans, gloves,
forks, knives, napkins,
you name it, anything
that a bakery might need.
We have more than 5,000
products in our portfolio.
So we operate in two
different business
models across North America.
One business model is the key
account business model, where
we take Dawn
manufactured products
like a cake mix or
an icing, and we
sell it directly to a large key
account like Walmart, 7-Eleven,
McDonald's, Panera, you name it.
And in this model, because
the customers are quite large,
they order in very
big quantities.
When Walmart orders
icing for their cakes,
they order like five
truckloads of icing.
So in this model,
we ship the products
directly from our plants
into the warehouses
of these large customers, which
is a simple business model.
Yet, we have a second
business model,
where we basically serve the
small and midsize accounts.
These are your neighborhood
bakeries or small donut shops
that are around the corner
in your neighborhood.
And these customers,
we sell them
the Dawn products, but also the
third-party sourced products.
And we consolidate all of these
things in our distribution
centers and deliver
them everyday.
And their orders are, by nature,
smaller and more complex.
There's a bag of this in it.
There's a pail of that in it.
And we need to
consolidate and make
very frequent small shipments
every day across North America.
So these are the two
business models by and large.
And while both business models
are very relevant and important
for Dawn, we do have a
much bigger heritage,
a well-invested
network, and also
a sustainable, competitive edge
on the small to midsize account
segment.
So I mean, this is the
bulk of our customer base.
And just like any other company,
this is more profitable for us
because these small customers
don't have the negotiation
power of a Walmart
or a McDonald's.
So this is why it's
strategically imperative for us
that we protect and grow
this segment of the market.
But how do we do that?
So as we think about how to
grow this segment of the market,
we had two separate
considerations,
or we looked at our business
through two different lenses.
One lens we used was the
product innovation lens.
Just like any other company,
we need to constantly innovate
our product portfolio
so we become relevant
and we differentiate ourselves.
And we do that.
I mean, we just introduced
gluten-free concept,
natural colors, natural
flavors, different formats,
and all that.
The problem is, we have 5,000
products in the portfolio.
So it's very difficult
to differentiate yourself
based on product because
every single product is not
significant enough
to make a difference.
It's a small fraction
of total sales.
That's why we just
looked at our business,
and we said, well, while
we have to innovate still,
we have to bring new bakery
products to the market, that's
just table stakes.
And we have to think about
a bigger mechanism, a higher
mechanism above product level to
differentiate ourselves almost
like a business model
innovation, an innovation
where the customer experience,
Dawn customer experience,
will be better if
we deliver a more
enjoyable and simplified Dawn
experience for our customers.
So we thought we need to
differentiate at that level.
The other lens we looked
at our business with
was the undeniable
factor that there
is a huge digital transformation
that's taking around us
in the food service and
bakery industries which
we are part of.
We see online ordering coming
into play more and more
every day with food
service distributors.
Amazon, they made
a public statement
with their B2B business model.
They said, we're going to go
after food service and bakery
industries.
And our direct
manufacturing competitors
are doing a lot
of digital things
to differentiate themselves.
So we just looked at
that, and we said,
we don't want to be left behind.
We actually have the opportunity
to be ahead of the curve
and preempt our peers if we
act fast in this digital area
because the digital
transformation in bakery
and food service industries
are still at their infancy.
So putting these
two things together,
the need to differentiate
and the need to stay
ahead of the curve,
we said, we're
going to invest in
digital technologies.
And we're going to embark
on a digital transformation
journey in partnership with
KPMG with the primary goal
to give a better customer
experience to Dawn customers,
hence, differentiate ourselves.
So of course, it all starts
with understanding our customer,
who the customer is,
and what they want.
And our customers are, as
I said, your neighborhood
bakeries, the donut shops.
And there's usually
a small venue
in which there is one
decision maker, the baker.
And this baker, by
definition, is an artist.
He or she is having a
lot of fun and pride,
and enjoying the art of baking.
They focus on the
passion of baking,
and they focus on the quality
and the taste of the food.
But while it's a
small establishment,
it's a very complex
operation, a bakery.
So there are a lot of other
elements of their business
that they need a lot of help.
And they rely on their suppliers
to provide those helps.
So that was one
thing we measured.
At Dawn, we constantly
look at what bakers need,
and what are some of
their biggest pain points?
What are their biggest
concerns, hopes, and fears?
And here's our latest research.
We understand that
the bakers, they
know technology is going
to be an important thing
in their lives.
It's going to play an important
role, but they don't know how.
And they don't know
how to make it happen.
So they need help.
In terms of product,
bakers want to make sure
that when they put
a product portfolio
and assortment in front
of their shoppers,
they want to make sure that
it is something that is driven
from the latest trends, latest
taste profiles, color profiles,
and the consumers will enjoy it.
And they also want to access
the highest quality bakery
ingredients at the lowest price
possible to make that happen.
And they need supported
recipes, et cetera.
Labor is probably their
biggest pain point
because they struggle to
find, recruit, train, retrain,
and retain skilled labor.
There's a huge shortage.
Financial, as I said,
bakers are artists.
They don't necessarily
immediately know
where they make money,
where they don't, or how
to prioritize their investments.
So they appreciate
a lot of consulting
in the area of financial.
Again, direct marketing,
targeting a certain consumer
group with the right products
and understanding their needs
and trends is not necessarily
an inherent skill set
that exists within bakeries.
And then last but not the least,
regulatory and compliance,
which is all about food law,
the labeling requirements, which
is constantly changing.
Bakers just want to
make sure they're, first
of all, compliant,
but they also have
access to audit
tools, certifications
which is required to
run their businesses.
So I mean, while these
are very specific
needs that we have identified,
the overarching theme is, yes,
they expect products from us.
They expect icings, and
cake mixes, and everything.
But they want a more
holistic help from us
to help with their business
and with the elements
of the business that are not
necessarily related to baking.
So combining this ambition to
go digital and the understanding
of the customers,
we just came up
with this vision
that says, we're
going to create a
digital bakery platform,
which we're going
to see the demo of.
And through that
bakery platform,
we just want to make
sure we provide products
online to our
customers, but we also
want to surround
them with services
on a digital
environment that they're
going to be needing to run their
businesses more effectively,
hence, differentiate ourselves.
So as a working charter,
this digital bakery platform
that we're going to
show you today is--
that we want to be an
indispensable partner
with the bakers.
And we want to create
a sustainable advantage
through the use of
technology and data
that otherwise they
wouldn't have access to.
And by doing that,
we want to help them.
And we want to help them achieve
their goals and aspirations.
So that's what we've
been working on.
So what does this
platform look like?
Conceptually imagine this
is a website or an app.
It may take different
shapes, but this
is for explanation purposes.
At the center of
it, there's going
to be a B2B product
online ordering facility
where they can basically
place their orders
and get their products online.
While online ordering
is nothing new--
it's been around for
20 years by now--
there's very little of
that in bakery industry.
So it's still very progressive,
simply because bakers are not
digital native people.
The operation is very
complex, product portfolio
is very fragmented, and pricing
is very customized per baker,
per product.
So there's an
inherent complexity,
which we are working on.
Once we get that rolling,
the second thing-- so these
are areas for bakers to
go into, conceptually.
We want to work on--
we are actually working on a
B2C online ordering facility
for our bakers.
The bakers want to engage
digitally with their consumers,
with their shoppers.
They want to make
sure that they have
an online ordering facility
through their stores,
but they don't know
how to get it done.
So we're working on
a turnkey solution
to provide to the
bakers so that they
can turn their own operation
into a digital, online-friendly
operation.
And they're going
to appreciate that.
We said labor is a big
issue for our bakers.
We are going to be connecting
to customized job search
engines in partnership
with Indeed, Monster,
or someone like ZipRecruiter
so that the bakers are
seeing who is available
and who they can recruit.
We also will connect
them to training videos
through YouTube.
And we're going to connect
them to certification programs
through educational
institutions.
In terms of marketing
and innovation,
at Dawn we have tremendous
knowledge of consumer desires,
wants, needs,
trends, everything,
and their behavioral
statistics and all that.
So we want to make
sure that we provide
these things to our bakers
in a digestible format that
makes sense to them and helps
them get the right product
assortment.
And also, we want to partner
with tools like Twilio.
We're going to be
helping the bakers
to run digital campaigns,
sales campaigns, which is
going to increase their sales.
And that's what they want.
We talked about
regulatory compliance.
There are a lot of
companies out there
that help companies
do these things.
For example, TrackMyRisks.com is
one of those digital companies
who are specialized in auditing,
audit tools, certification.
We want to work with them on
a bakery-specific solution
and plug them to our platform.
Same with financial, lots
of financial companies
who can help us with training,
measuring tools, investment
prioritization tools that we
can plug onto the platform.
And one of the things that
we're going to be doing
is in the side of operations,
think about a neighborhood
baker receiving a
large donut order,
like 500 donuts
for a college party
in the middle of the night.
Well, what they need to
do is, of course, make it,
and box it, and everything.
But to deliver it,
they usually have
a van, which is sometimes out.
So they need to wait for
that van to come back.
And the order is
delayed and all that.
Instead, we want to connect
them to a last mile delivery
service like
Postmates, Curbside,
so they don't need
that van anymore maybe.
They can just deliver their
product through those services.
By doing those
things, they're going
to be able to look at their
business and their assets
very differently.
And we can go on and
on, and be as creative
as we want with these things,
but the central idea here
is to provide our customers with
the online ordering facility
and the high quality
products, but also
surround them with these digital
services over the platform that
will help them with
their broader business.
And that's how we are planning
to differentiate ourselves
from those competitors
who are just selling
traditional products today.
With that, I'm going
to hand it off to Sam.
SAM GANGA: Thanks, Serhat.
I've heard this
story so many times.
And it's just incredible that
here's a 100-year-old company--
well, it'll be 100
years next year, right?
SERHAT UNSAL: Yes.
SAM GANGA: That's gone through
so many transformations.
This is the fourth or
fifth transformation.
If I remember, one of
the storylines that you
have that you talk about--
the first one
actually being when
we had the Great Depression.
The company reinvented
itself and is
going through so
many transformations.
So this is a company
that had actually worked
through quite a bit
of change and is now
ready for the next frontier.
So what I want to sort
of take you through is--
Serhat talked about
how entrenched
the entire value
proposition is with regards
to talking to the
customers, and frankly,
to the customers' customers,
which are consumers like you
and I, and really
building out, how
do you actually relate to them?
How do you engage with them?
How do you create
that stickiness?
But I want to unpack that
conceptual view, the value
proposition view and
the conceptual view,
which is the previous slide that
Serhat showed, and build on it,
and talk about what does
the logical model look
like when you unpack that?
And when you unpack that,
what does the physical model
look like, which is the
technical element needed
to make this a reality?
It's great to talk
about business agility,
but since it's so
entrenched in sort
of linking business and
technology together, linking
business, technology, and
digital capabilities together,
it's kind of incredible that
you had to bring all of us
together to actually
deliver a value proposition.
So I want to sort
of uncover that.
And when we get to the end of
the presentation, [INAUDIBLE]
will come up here
and do a quick demo
of where we see this going.
But before I get into
it, I want to talk
about this journey a little
bit because the journey that we
started together about
eight, nine months ago
didn't sort of happen with
the snap of the fingers.
There was a lot of interaction.
There was a lot of working
with Serhat's Dawn leadership
team, the board, Bob's
teams, that Bob's obviously
part of the leadership team,
but really getting everybody
to understand, what
is the value here?
Why should you make this pivot?
And why is it important?
It didn't happen with
the snap of fingers,
as Serhat will
definitely tell you.
So I want to sort
of walk through,
how do we actually go
through the process,
and what kind of
an approach did we
use to help people
think through it?
Not going to spend
too much time on it,
but it is what we think of as
our transformation framework.
This is business-led
digital transformation.
I want to be very clear.
And the journey
is what we really
believe in, because this
is not going to happen
in one year, two years.
It actually takes a
little bit of time.
And more importantly, it
needs to be sustainable.
You can't just expect that
this will happen in two years
and then you're done.
It's not an initiative.
It's a pivot for the whole
firm and the whole company.
We call it the
connected enterprise.
And really the
connected enterprise
has several key elements to it.
And I'm going to go
through all of it.
I'm just going to spend
about three or four
minutes going through the top
line capabilities, if you may.
The first, Serhat spent a
lot of time talking about it,
which is the fact that the
customer agenda is actually
ready for disruption.
Everything that we talk
about is customer-centric,
is outside in.
The surveys that
Serhat talked about,
the interactions
with the customers,
in this case, the artisan
bakers, the Walmarts
of the world, and
their consumers
was very important to inform
what the strategy needs
to look like.
So once we had that
in place, really
started take a look at
what kind of experiences
do we need to create in
order to enable that today
and down the road?
So this notion of creating
experiences and customer
experiences that are going
to really effectively enable
the strategy that was created
was an extremely important part
of it.
And, oh, by the way,
we were not looking
at just products and
services that Dawn provided.
We opened up the aperture
to say, what does
a customer really want from us?
And we created this
notion that we said
was more important
for you to understand
what experiences
the customer wants,
not what experiences
you could provide, still
an outside in perspective.
And then translating
that in terms
of organizational
capabilities to deliver
number one and number two.
How do you deliver
profitable growth?
How do you deliver this from
an organizational capability?
Because nobody else
is going to do it.
You have to do it.
And you have to transform
your organization to do that.
When you've looked
at all of this
and you pivot into what
capabilities are necessary,
how do you break
down these silos
that we're normally
used to, whether it's
supply chain only this or
your customer service team
only does this?
How do you break down these
barriers between front, middle,
and back office?
And how do you
create an environment
that allows transformation
to happen more naturally?
That was really what we were
jointly working on together.
And so there are eight
capabilities that we believe.
And this is all
based on research,
by the way, that we've done
over the last three years,
not just from
talking to customers,
but working with external
parties who have actually
thought through what these
capabilities need to be.
And they've done service for us.
We've done research.
We really entrench that
research in terms of outcomes
and constantly refined it.
I'm not going to go through
these eight capabilities,
just going to point out
a couple, three of them.
The first one is
kind of obvious.
I think a lot of us are
here because we believe
that insight-driven
strategies and actions are
core to the way a business
would behave in a digital world.
What's interesting is that
one of the services KPMG
does on an annual basis
with CEOs across the globe,
we found that while
everybody sort of believes
that this is their
strategy, 78% of CEOs
actually don't use
data-driven insights
to inform their decisions.
They still go with their gut.
I'm not suggesting
that gut is not
important for a
CEO in particular,
but this is something
that we are learning,
and we're trying to
inform everybody.
But this, we believe,
is core to one
of the capabilities required
for a transformation.
Serhat is not one of
those CEOs, by the way.
[LAUGHING]
But the second one,
of course, Serhat
talked about, which is the
innovation, and products,
and services, not only
innovation of existing products
that you sell to your
customers, but also
digital twins that you
want to sell or enhance
your existing products with.
Experience-centricity,
that's something
that is talked about a lot,
where your customers really
are the center of
your universe, and you
want to deliver an experience,
not just a product for them.
And this is not just for
the customer, but also
your employees so that
they're serving customers
more effectively.
And that's extremely
important as well.
Seamless commerce and
seamless interactions, this
is about omnichannel
capabilities
so that if you
start a transaction,
or if you start an inquiry,
or you start a conversation
on one channel, which
could be digital, that you
don't lose track of it.
You don't lose track of it when
somebody walks in the store,
or walks up to your sales
agent, or whoever it might be.
The piece that is
a challenge as you
start to unfold all
these capabilities
is the response of
operations and supply chain.
Supply chain is sort
of making a move--
and we believe this is an
important move-- from being
make-centric and cost-centric
to be customer-centric
and commercially oriented,
sort of moving upstream
so that you're not just
thinking of yourself as, I got
to deliver the best
product, create the best
product at the cheapest price.
And so we can go on
and on through this.
Suffice it to say that
we believe, obviously,
the alignment of people, talent,
whether it's growing talent
internally, changing
the way people think,
or externally hiring,
talent is very important.
And finally, a digitally-enabled
architecture, which we
will talk about in a
little bit more detail.
So I'm not going to
delve into details there.
Serhat already talked
about the importance
of the partner
ecosystem and the fact
that you want to
welcome partners.
And what's very refreshing
about this is none of this
is sort of behind
some firewall setting.
And Serhat and Bob go out
and talk to their customers,
talk to their partners.
They're very open about
what they want to do,
which is sort of what
Serhat calls the open source
world of businesses.
You want to sort
of share as much
as you can so that
you're inviting people
into your ecosystem.
And you're creating
possibilities
that you never knew possible.
And so that's something that
we want, creating opportunities
that you never knew possible.
So one of the
things I'll end with
is that as we started to
unpack this more and more,
we found that as
we talked about it
and began to monitor companies
that were using this,
companies that use this kind
of a framework, not exactly
the framework, but really
invested in those capabilities
were twice as likely to
succeed in their transformation
efforts.
And this is something that,
whether you believe in exactly
all those capabilities or you
want to modify some of this,
this is directionally
where we believe
companies will need to go in
order to survive and thrive
in the digital age.
And this is where,
when Serhat opened,
we really are trying to link
those two together and saying,
there is no business strategy
and digital strategy.
It's one and the same thing.
And you have to understand
how they work together
and how you would
sustain them together.
So with that said, and as a
backdrop for how we actually
went through this
journey, I want
to sort of transition a little
bit into where we left off
with our story and
Serhat talking about,
what does Dawn look like
as a platform company?
Conceptually, these are the
products, services, areas,
categories that we
believe is important,
that Dawn believes is very
important for futureproofing
the business.
At the heart of this, of
course, is all the data
that you're going to collect.
This is a fairly
seasonal business.
Bakers have to react.
There's a lot of bakery business
all throughout the year,
but when they get into
Thanksgiving or now coming up
with Easter,
there's a big spike.
When are they actually
looking for labor?
What kind of labor
are they looking for?
How often do they
look for that labor?
What can they pay for it?
You are collecting that data.
Even if you anonymize it,
it's very powerful data.
And so each one of these bubbles
or clouds that you look at
creates and puts
out so much data
that we believe that
is actually how we're
going to keep this a
sustainable, competitive edge
for Dawn and for their bakers.
So let's sort of unpack and
go from a conceptual view
into a more of a
logical view, and then
into a technology view.
So if you look at this
a little differently,
in order for us to be able
to create what we think
of as a plug and
play architecture,
there are two
fundamental elements
that are necessary,
even before you get
down to collecting the data.
To be able to create these
business services that Serhat
talked about, whether it's
connecting up with Indeed,
or a gig economy provider of
resources, or whoever you have,
there's two things
that we wanted
to sort of ensure that we do.
The first one was
working together.
The Dawn team said,
it needs to be
a microservices-based
architecture.
Whether you're
building your own,
you're plugging something
in, you essentially
need the ability to
plug into a chassis.
And that microservices
architecture
has to enable that.
The second piece is that using
APIs that are readily available
is an excellent way to
accelerate, and frankly,
not only accelerate but also
run test and learn cycles.
And we're doing some of that and
exploring that as we go along.
When we go into the details,
we'll talk about some of that.
But all of this, whatever
the areas are that Bob
talked about in the--
I'm sorry, Serhat talked
about in the previous slide
with operations and marketing
technology knowledge,
et cetera, what we
believe is that you
would need these to plug in to a
technology backbone, what we're
calling the core business
platform for Dawn, Dawn Core
Business Platform.
So what does that look like?
Today, that is built on
a Google GCP backbone.
Think of that as the chassis.
The chassis is where everything
is going to plug into.
And the chassis obviously
has core capabilities, which
we'll talk about in a second.
But it also has
business solutions.
We don't think of YouTube
as a business solution.
We just think of it as a cool
place to watch videos roughly.
But Dawn has already
started the process
of creating a Dawn channel.
Somebody knows,
what does it look
like when you're creating a
very specific product or a end
product for your customer?
And what do you need in order
to be able to create that?
Because this is an art for them.
This is their passion.
They want to learn about
new techniques for frosting,
or to create a new
kind of a cake,
or what's coming up in the
food services industry that
is relevant to them.
So when we look at
this, we are actually
looking at plugging in things
that are fairly native to what
Google already does.
And we're calling those
Google Business Solutions.
It's still part of Google Cloud,
but it's a business solution
that is provided.
It could be AdWords.
It could be Express
Shopping List.
It could be Recommendations
AI that we're going to use.
But there are
things that you have
to always create by yourself.
One of them is the
commerce engine.
We do believe that in order to
achieve the goals that Serhat
talked about, you are going to
need to transact fundamentally.
Well, that's not native in the
Google Cloud, yet at least.
But we will be using
a commerce engine
that we will plug and
play from elsewhere.
We will be creating our own
customer service transformation
interaction models.
We will be creating things
that are specific to what
Dawn needs, curated by
Dawn, created by Dawn,
but they will all ultimately
plug into the same chassis.
And we believe that's
extremely important for us.
When you sort of unpack
this a little bit more,
what we're seeing is
that we're going to use--
I mean, this is not a technical
deep dive presentation,
but I'm going to do the
best I can to sort of cover
the top elements.
You are going to have
a serverless computing
architecture.
You are going to have
an elastic cloud.
You are going to have all
those things that are normal,
expected, container engines,
whatever you want to call it.
You are going to do all of that.
And that's sort of
the top line item.
You are going to use BigQuery.
You're going to do all of that.
But there are elements
that you need in order
to deliver this business
agility, which will only
come from really thinking
about your ability
to not only subscribe to
APIs, but also publish APIs.
So as much as you're
subscribing to an API--
and we'll talk about
that in a second--
we're also going to publish APIs
that other people might use.
Maybe it's the organizer
of this event that needs--
I don't know how many donuts
we had in the morning.
Maybe we didn't have any donuts.
But maybe they need
2,000 donuts a day.
They could subscribe
to this and find a way
to engage with artisanal
bakers to deliver those 2,000
donuts a day in the morning.
So when we look at the
enabling technologies
and what it takes to be
able to really unpack this,
there are two elements to it.
The first is the
ability to sort of have
a conversational interface.
And that's what we're
using Dialogflow for.
I'm going to literally just not
talk about the top row there
because I think we already
have enough sessions that
cover those.
We're going to talk about the
business elements of this.
The first one is Dialogflow.
And we'll talk a little
bit more about it,
but Dialogflow is essentially
the interaction engine
for conversational commerce,
extremely powerful.
If you don't know about it, I
would recommend you learn more
about it because it really
brings across the notion
that whether you're interacting
with a customer using Google
Home, or whether you're
using your mobile phone,
or whether you're using
some other element that you
don't know about today, it
will be extremely powerful.
The second that we
found very valuable
is the ability to
store session data.
Because your performance
of your conversation
is important, and
the speech to text,
the text to speech
elements are important.
You will need to have
a caching capability.
And we're using
Firebase for that.
Cloud communications,
we use Twilio
to be able to start using
the ability to alert people
quickly, get them informed.
And if you don't
know Twilio, I would
recommend you get to know them.
Now you're going to get into--
I'm going to talk about
the commerce engine
next, which is commercetools.
It's a ground up microservices
architecture-based commerce
engine.
We found it to be
extremely powerful,
easy to plug and play,
easy to get off the ground,
and really curate your overall
interactive experience.
And commercetools
is, we believe,
one of the vendors
out there that's
doing a great amount
of work around,
how do you actually
plug into more
of a cloud-based, native
microservices architecture?
Now this interesting part
that I left out in the middle
is actually one of
the elements where
we believe we're
going to generate
a lot of business interest.
This is what we think
of as one aspect
of our fulfillment engine.
Now one of the things
that came out--
and we're obviously
learning from the market,
and is a huge test and learn
cycle that works pretty
quickly--
is that last mile delivery
for fulfillment is important.
The example that
you used, Serhat, I
got to deliver 500 cupcakes.
Now I need the
ingredients tomorrow.
How are you going
to get it to me?
You can either use
Dawn's logistics network
to be able to deliver
it, which is not
meant for last mile delivery.
Or you can engage by
plugging and playing
Postmates or somebody
else to be able to do it.
And what we're
saying is eventually
we expect that
these partnerships,
whether it's a Postmate
or whether it's
somebody else,
Curbside, what have you,
you're going to
start using these
to be able to actually deliver
products in the last mile.
And we're going to see that
when we get to the demo.
We've actually plugged that in.
What we also found is that
it's not a one size fits all.
You could use
Postmates in New York.
You could use Curbside in Miami.
You could use your own
network in Chicago.
You can order whatever you want.
Ultimately, you have
the ability to plug
in business APIs,
business services,
and rapidly get
it off the ground.
In terms of, of
course, when you're
looking at these
business APIs, it's
complicated because there are
a lot of operational factors.
What used to be the longest
pole in the tent, which
is connect up the whole
infrastructure from Postmates,
connect up this,
make sure it works--
we got it done in a week.
At least the first shot at
it, we got it done in a week.
And that was actually a
big revelation for us,
because it is about
the speed of business.
This is about the clock
speed of business.
And if technology
doesn't support that,
we've got a big problem.
And this is really
what it's meant to do,
is to accelerate that process.
For those of you sort of
interested in the architecture
diagram, we didn't disappoint.
So we do have one of the more
complex ones that I've seen.
It's actually a very
simple one compared
to where we are going to be.
But this is setting up
the demo a little bit,
just to give you a flavor for--
I'm not going to steal
[INAUDIBLE] thunder here,
but really what I want
to communicate here
is the fact that we have
separated out the modalities
of interaction from the APIs.
The APIs is actually where, in
some sense, the magic happens.
And you can look at
it as, those of you
who are technologists, and
say plugging in the API
is extremely important,
the resiliency of the API,
the performance of
the service itself,
et cetera, et cetera, et cetera.
But we're seeing that
a lot of the magic
is beginning to happen
and will happen,
continue to happen on the front
end because of the devices
that are proliferating,
businesses.
We foresee a
situation where there
could be a Google device sitting
at every artisanal baker.
And they are going to
actually use a device
to interact with Dawn,
not sort of get on a phone
or do something else.
We believe that
that is extremely
important for the future of this
platform that is being created.
And [INAUDIBLE]
will go through why
we believe that's the case
from an experience perspective,
speaking about the
connected enterprise story
and how important
experiences are part of it.
For the purposes
of our conversation
today, one of the things
I want to point out
is the entire API gateway--
I shouldn't say
the entire piece.
Let me clarify.
The API gateway is
based on Apigee.
Now not every API is
available through Apigee,
so sometimes you have to go
directly to the provider,
to the service provider and get
the API, and connect to them.
Commercetools is
an example of that.
It's not available-- at
least when we shut it off,
it wasn't available
as a part of Apigee.
But Postmates is.
And we accelerated our
process because we used
Apigee to connect the back end.
So obviously, this
is a drill down
off the actual
architecture that we have.
There's a bigger
architecture that
brings in a lot of the machine
learning capabilities, the data
capabilities that are extremely
important for the growth
of this.
So with that, I'm going to
hand it over to [INAUDIBLE]
to actually go through the demo.
And then we'll have about seven
to eight minutes for a Q&A
at the end of this.
SPEAKER 3: Thanks, Sam.
So before we begin,
is there a clicker?
There, thank you.
It's really important
to understand
first the actual
experience that we're
looking to enhance for
a lot of these bakers.
So throughout this
journey what we've done
is we've actually gone and
visited a lot of these bakeries
across the country.
And we spent the day
with them to understand
what their current
experience really is.
And what we found
was a lot of them,
they handle every aspect
of their business.
It's not only honing
their craft and their art,
but it's also really effectively
running their business.
So they're in the back.
They're actually the ones in
the kitchens creating the goods.
They are then moving over,
washing up, and going over
to their laptops, and calling
up vendors, tracking orders,
bill payments, and then also
handling customer service.
They're also looking
up new recipes,
looking on social media.
They're trying to
find out, how do
I get inspired to build
what I love doing?
So with that in mind, we
created a demo to see,
how do we handle and enhance
this experience for them
so they're not running
around everywhere?
And it really creates a
seamless interaction with them.
So with that in mind--
if we could transition
to the demo screen?
So there are many
mediums you could
use to essentially
interact with this platform
here, which we are
calling Baker Assist.
For this situation, we've
used the Google Assistant
mobile app.
So just to engage with
it, one would just
have to start off by saying,
talk to Baker Assist.
SIRI: All right.
Here's the test version
of Baker Assist.
BAKER ASSIST: Hi.
I'm Baker Assist.
Have a question about
ingredients or baking
techniques?
I'm here to answer.
You may also choose to subscribe
to baker alerts to receive
upcoming instructional videos by
asking "Alert me on new tips."
SPEAKER 3: That
sounds pretty cool.
So I think I'm going
to ask to be alerted.
Alert me on new tips.
BAKER ASSIST: OK, I'll
start alerting you.
I noticed that the
NYC Autumn Food
Festival is trending
on social media
and will take place
near your location
within the next several days.
Some type of pumpkin dessert
might be great for this event.
SPEAKER 3: So you see here
they're pairing location.
They're able to do the
research and provide
all that information right
to you at your fingertips.
I mean, this sounds really neat.
And it's right near me.
Pumpkin desserts during
autumn is always great.
So I'm thinking a
pumpkin dessert.
Maybe I want to learn how
to make pumpkin donuts.
Show me a video on how
BAKER ASSIST: Here's
the instructional video
for making pumpkin donut.
SPEAKER 3: Perfect.
So I can access this.
SPEAKER 4: Hey, guys.
It's [INAUDIBLE].
And today, we're making
these pumpkin donuts
that are perfect for fall.
SPEAKER 3: So you see, it's
called YouTube and figured out
a repository of
videos that we have
to be inspired in terms
of how to make new goods.
And now I want to know a little
bit more detail regarding
these pumpkin donuts I've
just learned to make.
Show me the ingredients for
the pumpkin donut recipe.
BAKER ASSIST: Here are the
ingredients for pumpkin donut.
SPEAKER 3: And so I take a
look at these ingredients.
And I see one of the ingredients
here is whole wheat flour.
Now as Serhat mentioned,
a lot of these bakers,
they're really entrenched
in their communities.
And I know my community.
And I know that they're
very health conscious.
So maybe I want
gluten-free flour instead.
Are there gluten-free
substitutes for wheat flour?
BAKER ASSIST: Sure, here are a
list of wheat flour substitutes
that are gluten free--
almond flour, buckwheat flour,
amaranth flour, teff flour,
brown rice flour.
SPEAKER 3: Brown rice
flour seems pretty cool,
so add 5 kg of brown
rice flour to my cart.
BAKER ASSIST: Great, 5
kilograms of brown rice flour
is successfully added to cart.
SPEAKER 3: Add the pumpkin
donut recipe to my cart.
BAKER ASSIST: Great,
the pumpkin donuts
products are added to cart.
SPEAKER 3: So instead of
adding each individual item,
I can add the entire
block of items.
View my cart.
BAKER ASSIST: Here
are your cart details.
SPEAKER 3: Looks pretty good.
Place order.
BAKER ASSIST: Great.
Your order has been
placed successfully.
Your order will arrive in
three to four business days.
However, it looks like
the NYC Autumn Food
Festival is only two days away.
Would you like to opt
for fast delivery?
SPEAKER 3: Well, that's a
good thing they told me that.
So of course, I
want fast delivery.
Yes.
BAKER ASSIST: You have opted
for expedited delivery.
SPEAKER 3: Great.
So now as the
baker, I can go in,
take a look at
where my order is.
And I'm based out of New York.
And I can see that
my order is waiting
to be accepted right now and
will be delivered fairly soon.
And I can track it.
I can go away and handle
the rest of my business.
And whenever I feel like
checking up on my order,
I can do that, as
well as I know I'll
be alerted on the status of
my order as the day goes on.
[MUSIC PLAYING]